.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Ich habe von einem Streit gehört,
der hier im idyllischen
Obertoggenburg herrschen soll.
Zwei Bergbahnen, die viele Jahre
gemeinsam ein Skigebiet betrieben,
sind nun zerstritten und getrennt.
Im Tal spricht man
von einem Eisernen Vorhang.
Auf der einen Seite
die Toggenburg Bergbahnen
von Unterwasser und Alt Sankt Johann.
Das Sagen
hat hier ein reiches Ehepaar.
Es hat schon Millionen von Franken
investiert
und will nun noch die Nachbars-
bergbahn von Wildhaus übernehmen.
Mélanie und Matthias Eppenberger -
sie ursprünglich Französin,
er Toggenburger.
Ich bin der Sohn eines Tierarztes
aus dem Toggenburg,
der spricht und denkt
wie ein Toggenburger.
Das ist doch ein Idealfall.
Wir haben nicht
irgendeinen chinesischen Milliardär,
der zufälligerweise
hier etwas Geld versteckt.
Dass wir über Monate hinweg ...
... versucht haben, im Gespräch
zu einer Lösung zu kommen,
wird oft ausgeblendet.
Dass wir über Monate einfach
an eine Wand gesprochen haben.
Auf der anderen Seite
die Bergbahnen von Wildhaus.
Eine traditionelle
Publikumsgesellschaft
mit über 2'000 Aktionären
und der Gemeinde als Grossaktionärin.
Seit 30 Jahren
ist hier Jakob Rhyner, genannt Jacky,
Verwaltungsratspräsident.
Er wehrt sich gegen die Übernahmever-
suche durch die reichen Investoren.
Ich respektiere ihre Meinung.
Sie vielleicht meine nicht.
Aber ich bin
schon verdammt vorsichtig,
mit jemandem eine Ehe einzugehen,
der mir schon ein Messer
an die Kehle gehalten
oder eine Pistole
auf die Brust gedrückt hat.
Ich als Lediger darf das sagen.
Bergbahnen sind in der Schweiz nicht
nur eine Frage von Geld und Schnee,
sondern auch von lokalen Emotionen.
Es ist Oktober 2020.
Ich habe eine Einladung
von den Bergbahnen Wildhaus erhalten.
Ja ...
Das ist die neue Bahn.
Das ist jetzt hier.
Das ist Wildhaus.
Und dort drüben ...
... ist dann schon
Toggenburg Bergbahnen.
Das ist die Konkurrenz.
(Mann) Ah, dort drüben, ja.
Gefeiert
wird dieser neue Sechsersessellift.
Er ersetzt mehrere
über 50 Jahre alte Skilifte.
Geladen
sind Aktionäre und Unternehmer,
aber auch Vertreter
anderer Skigebiete aus der Region.
Morgen.
- Morgen.
Wie geht's? Ist ja Full House hier.
- Ja.- Sind Sie bereit?
Nur Mélanie Eppenberger,
die Präsidentin der benachbarten
Toggenburg Bergbahnen,
finde ich unter den Gästen nicht.
Haben Sie von der Konkurrenz
Toggenburg Bergbahnen
auch jemanden eingeladen?
Nein, haben wir nicht.
Das wäre unehrlich gewesen.
Sie wollte die Bahn verhindern.
Daher lade ich sie nicht
zu meinem Gründungsfest ein.
Die Regierung
ist aber auch nicht eingeladen.
Die Kantonsregierung? Warum?
- Ja.
Sie verweigerte uns ja
die 4 oder 5 Mio. Fr. -
aus nicht gerade
überzeugenden Gründen.
Ja, ja.
- Sie verlangte ja,
dass wir
ein gemeinsames Ticket machen.
Das ist an sich nicht unvernünftig.
Das wollten wir ja immer.
Aber die Unterwasser-Seite
hat das ständig abgelehnt.
* Sanfte Alphornklänge *
Für die Finanzierung
der neuen Sesselbahn
mussten schlussendlich
Freunde von Jakob Rhyner
mit über 2 Mio. Fr. aushelfen.
Dies, weil der Kanton St. Gallen
sich geweigert hatte,
bereitliegende Bundesgelder von
4 Mio. Fr. als Darlehen zu gewähren.
Die Begründung:
das fehlende gemeinsame Winterticket
der Bergbahnen Wildhaus
und der Toggenburg Bergbahnen.
In Wildhaus macht man dafür
Mélanie Eppenberger verantwortlich.
Sie habe mit ihrer Blockadehaltung
den Bau der Sesselbahn
verhindern wollen.
Aufgrund der Erfahrungen,
die wir gemacht haben ...
... sprechen wir ihr
in gewisser Weise die Kenntnis ab.
Warum war man gegen diese Bahn,
die alle befürworteten?
Die Bahnbauer natürlich, aber auch
die Gemeinde und der Kanton.
Ich habe eine E-Mail
von Regierungsrat Ammann erhalten,
in der er sagte,
er unterstütze das Projekt.
Es sei vernünftig, dass man
bald kaputte Skilifte ersetze.
Aber sie war dagegen.
Wir haben aber nie gesprochen.
Sie hat die Unterlagen
nie eingesehen.
Einfach, weil es nicht ihrer stra-
tegischen Zielsetzung entspricht,
uns zu übernehmen.
Feindlich zu übernehmen.
Skifahren sei kein öffentliches Gut,
eine staatliche Finanzierung unnötig,
heisst es bei Eppenbergers.
Sie seien aber nicht schuld daran,
dass es für die Wildhauser
keine Darlehen vom Kanton gab.
Ich empfand das als Ungerechtigkeit,
ohne ...- Aber es ist nicht neu.
Aber die Wildhauser sagten, sie seien
bereit für ein gemeinsames Ticket.
Aber sie konnten nichts machen,
solange Sie blockieren.
Ein gemeinsames Ticket
und dann staatliche Unterstützung:
Das ist Pflästerlipolitik.
Und diese hat langfristig
keine Chance.
Langfristig hat nur eine gesunde
wirtschaftliche Struktur Chancen,
die in der Lage ist,
die Zukunft selber zu finanzieren.
Wogegen ich mich auch immer wehre:
Dass die Toggenburger
die Philosophie des armen Mannes
aus dem Toggenburg kultivieren.
Sie sagen,
wir bräuchten Unterstützung
und der Staat sieht die Toggenburger
als unterstützungsbedürftig an.
Der Toggenburger ist ein Starker.
Das Toggenburger Volk ist ein gutes.
Wir können das selber machen.
Wir sind nicht auf
staatliche Unterstützung angewiesen.
Matthias Eppenberger
hat die finanziellen Mittel dazu.
Jahrelang hat er als Privatbankier
gutes Geld verdient.
Seit Ende der 90er-Jahre investierte
er in die Bergbahnen von Toggenburg.
Zuerst brachten er und seine Frau
die Fusion der Bahnen Unterwasser
und Alt Sankt Johann durch.
Dann bauten sie ein neues
Bergrestaurant auf dem Chäserrugg -
geplant von den bekannten Architekten
Herzog & de Meuron.
Kosten: rund 13 Mio. Fr.
Man wollte vermehrt
auch Nicht-Skifahrer
auf den Chäserrugg bringen.
Dazu kam noch eine neue
Zehnergondelbahn für 24 Mio. Fr.
Die Stationen dafür haben ebenfalls
Herzog & de Meuron geplant.
Ein guter Teil wurde jedoch
durch Kredite und Leasing finanziert.
Mein Investment rechnet sich,
wenn das Unternehmen gesund ist
und Dividenden zahlen kann.
Ich brauche keine Verdoppelung
oder Verdreifachung des Einsatzes,
wie das ein Spekulant will,
der im Silicon Valley investiert.
Darum investiere ich
im Toggenburg Valley,
weil ich Zeit habe
und an die Leute und das Tal glaube.
Allerdings: In dieser Zeit
der teuren Grossinvestitionen
begannen auch die Angriffe
gegen die Bergbahnen Wildhaus.
Es ging um die Verteilung
der gemeinsamen Ticketeinnahmen.
Die Eppenbergers kritisierten,
sie müssten zu viel an
die Bergbahnen Wildhaus überweisen,
weil diese mehr
auf hohe Frequenzen setzten.
Das war der Anfang vom Ende
des gemeinsamen Tickets.
Der Ball liegt eigentlich bei Ihnen.
Sie haben das Ticket ja gekündigt.
Nein.
Das grosse Übel ist,
dass die gemeinsamen Tickets auf ei-
nem Frequenzsystem aufgebaut haben.
Jedes Gebiet
war dann quasi dazu motiviert,
den Kunden wie im Hamsterrad zu
frequentem Skifahren zu motivieren.
Das passte halt nicht
für die Qualitätsstrategie,
wie wir sie gerne fahren.
Und daran scheiterte das Ticket,
nicht an der Frage, ob die einen
es wollten und die anderen nicht.
Es machte klick,
als die Investitionen ...
... im Chäserrugg mit der Bahn
und dem Restaurant enorm hoch waren.
Dort machte es bei ihr -
verständlicherweise - klick.
Sie fand, man müsse schauen,
woher man das Geld nehme.
Dann kam der Vorwurf an uns,
dass wir seit Jahrzehnten zu viel
Geld aus dem Topf nehmen würden.
Beim Streit um die Verteilung
der gemeinsamen Ticketeinnahmen
fand man keine Lösung.
Die Eppenbergers gaben sich mit dem
Chäserrugg alleine nicht zufrieden.
Sie entschieden sich
für einen Schritt,
mit dem sie im Tal
viel Vertrauen einbüssten:
dem Versuch, einer feindlichen
Übernahme der Bergbahnen Wildhaus.
Wieder einmal
tobt im St. Gallischen Toggenburg
ein Kampf um die Bergbahnen.
Diesmal herrscht dicke Luft,
weil die Toggenburg Bergbahnen AG
ihre Konkurrentin,
die Bergbahnen Wildhaus AG,
übernehmen will.
Die Toggenburg Bergbahnen
boten lediglich 25 Fr. pro Aktie
der Bergbahnen Wildhaus,
obwohl diese
einen Steuerwert von 200 Fr. hatten -
und das per Zeitungsinserat.
"Der frechste Übernahmeversuch
der Schweiz",
titelte die Zeitung "Blick".
Der Verwaltungsrat von Wildhaus sei
erst am Vorabend informiert worden.
Der Ärger war gross.
Das Kaufangebot ist eine Zumutung
und auf Deutsch gesagt
eine Frechheit.
Man will eine Firma
bzw. ein Unternehmen kaufen,
bei dem der Steuerwert pro Aktie
bei 200 Fr. liegt.
Und davon will man 12,5 %,
also 25 Fr., bezahlen,
um in den Genuss
einer guten Firma zu kommen.
Mélanie Eppenberger
konnte nicht genug Aktionäre
von ihrem Angebot überzeugen.
Aber sie musste sich immer wieder
dafür rechtfertigen.
Ein Angebot
ist ein Angebot und kein Zwang.
Verstehen Sie, dass viele
das Angebot als frech ansehen?
Das Angebot
beruht auf dem Wunsch nach Fusion.
Es ist ein konkretes Zeichen
für eine Fusion.
Ich würde mir wünschen, dass
die Partnergesellschaft das als ...
... Einladung wahrnimmt,
Fusionsverhandlungen durchzuführen.
Die feindliche Übernahme misslang.
Seither heisst es
vonseiten der Toggenburg Bergbahnen:
Ohne Fusion gibt es kein
gemeinsames Winterticket mehr.
Der Gipfel der Streitereien:
Das erste Mal seit 19 Jahren
gibt es keine Verbindung
zwischen den beiden Skigebieten mehr
und entsprechend
auch kein gemeinsames Ticket.
Das attraktive Skigebiet,
das zwei Jahrzehnte lang
verbunden war, wurde somit getrennt.
Seither gehen beide Bahnen
ihre eigenen Wege.
Wildhaus verkauft Tickets
nur für sein Gebiet,
Chäserrugg nur für seines.
Die Ticketpreise sind dabei
nur wenig tiefer als früher.
Die Verbindungsstrecken zwischen den
Gebieten, einst für viel Geld gebaut,
sind geschlossen -
schon den zweiten Winter.
Im Tal stösst das
auf absolutes Unverständnis.
An den Stammtischen können wir
wegen Corona nicht nachfragen -
so versuchen wir es
beim Take-away im Dorf.
Grüezi.
- Hallo.
Im Geschäft merken Sie es nicht?
- Doch, doch, man merkt es schon.
Im Moment hat es sehr viele Leute,
aber Corona macht natürlich
einen Strich durch die Rechnung.
Letztes Jahr ... Sicher merkt man,
dass viele Gäste nicht mehr kommen.
Ah, doch?
- Leute, die jahrelang kamen.
- Ja, ja, das ganz sicher.
Ich finde es schade,
dass sie nicht mehr zusammen sind.
Sehr schade.
Das ist ein schützenswertes Tal,
in dem alle zusammenhalten müssten.
Sogar. Und woran liegt es?
An den sturen Köpfen.
Auch Hotelier Paul Beutler
ist verärgert.
Der gebürtige Zürcher
ist seit 45 Jahren im Obertoggenburg
und besitzt hier drei Hotels,
u.a. das Säntis in Unterwasser.
Das ist 70er-Jahre-Stil.
- Das ist so, ja.
Ja, es wurde Ende der 70er gemacht.
Okay, also ...
Hier haben wir die Bergkette
mit dem Säntis
und dem Wildhuser Schafberg.
Der Hotelier
ist natürlich nicht glücklich.
Er nicht und die Gäste auch nicht.
Für die Gäste ist es ...
... eine Abwertung.
Der Gast geht gerne hier rauf
und fährt da Ski,
oder auch in Wildhaus.
Er geht dann aber
gerne mal oben durch
und hat ein grösseres Skigebiet.
Das ist heute einfach in.
Man hat gerne grosse Skigebiete
und nicht möglichst kleine.
Und wenn er da drüben Ski fährt
und hierherkommt,
muss er zweimal bezahlen.
Das ist nicht in.
Derzeit sind seine Hotels
wegen Corona unterbelegt.
Aber auch das fehlende
gemeinsame Skiticket
wirke sich schlecht
aufs Geschäft aus.
Man hat weniger Gäste
in der Restauration und im Hotel.
Wir hatten hauptsächlich Absagen
in den Ferienwohnungen.
Die sagen sich:
"Wenn wir nur noch
die Hälfte des Skigebiets haben,
müssen wir mal
etwas anderes ausprobieren."
Für uns ist das keine gute Sache.
Wie sehen Sie das Investment
der Familie Eppenberger?
Was Mélanie bzw.
die Familie Eppenberger gemacht hat,
indem sie die Investoren gefunden
haben und die Bahnen und ...
Was sie gemacht haben,
ist eigentlich eine super Sache,
auch für die Region.
Diese Zehnergondeln sind super.
Eigentlich
haben sie alles gut gemacht,
ausser dass sie nicht mehr
mit den anderen zusammenarbeiten.
Das ist nicht gut.
Bedauerlich finden den Streit
viele auch deswegen,
weil die Gemeinden
Alt Sankt Johann und Wildhaus
vor Jahren erst fusioniert haben.
Am Berg klappt allerdings nicht,
was im Tal möglich war.
Das ärgert auch
den Wildhauser Hansruedi Peterer.
Es kann niemand verstehen,
warum es so ist. Es ist schade.
Es wäre ein schönes Skigebiet,
aber so ist es halbiert.
Was mich mehr stört, ist,
dass man auch die Leute trennt.
Man würde gerne mit Freunden
von da hinten Ski fahren.
Das Problem ist einfach,
dass man das so nicht kann.
Sonst muss man
zwei Saisonkarten lösen.
Das stört uns.
Wie ist es in der Bevölkerung
im Dorf?
Es ist ja jetzt eine Gemeinde.
Wie ist es dort?
Du konntest fast nirgends -
also,
als man noch hineingehen konnte -
an einen Tisch sitzen, ohne dass
das irgendwann zum Thema wurde.
Das wurde eigentlich immer
diskutiert.
Im Moment ist es schwierig,
weil man nicht untereinander
diskutieren kann.
Da sind wir
auch wieder eingeschränkt.
Es ist immer ein Thema,
auf jeden Fall. Ja, ja.
Und wer ist schuld daran?
Ja, wer ist schuld?
Wenn zwei streiten ...
Alleine kann man nicht streiten.
Es braucht zwei.
Insbesondere in den sozialen Medien
schieben jedoch viele Mélanie
Eppenberger den Schwarzen Peter zu.
Die, die nicht zufrieden mit ihr
sind, nennen sie "die Französin".
Das ist mir aufgefallen - in Leser-
briefen oder Facebook-Kommentaren.
Jacky Rhyner sagt,
sie sei eine Monarchistin.
Und hier gebe es eine Demokratie,
sagt er.
Es ist November 2020.
Mein erster Besuch bei
Mélanie Eppenberger im Toggenburg.
Sie sagt, die Angriffe auf sie
hätten mitunter auch fremden-
und frauenfeindliche Züge angenommen.
Die gebürtige Französin
ist seit rund zehn Jahren
Präsidentin und Gesicht
der Toggenburg Bergbahnen.
Ihr Mann Matthias
hält sich meist im Hintergrund.
Kennengelernt hatten sich die beiden
an der Hochschule in St. Gallen.
Sie sagt, Mensch und Natur im Toggen-
burg seien ihr ans Herz gewachsen.
Da ist ein Reh. Oder eine Gämse?
- Ah, eine Gämse, ja.
Für die Grossinvestitionen -
wie das Gipfelrestaurant
von Herzog & de Meuron -
haben die Eppenbergers verschiedene
Geldgeber mit ins Boot geholt,
u.a. die einheimische
Skisprunglegende Simon Ammann.
Er soll mit über 1 Mio. Fr.
beteiligt sein.
Uns gegenüber
wollte Ammann sich nicht äussern.
Mit dabei ist auch einer
der reichsten Schweizer:
der ehemalige Armaturenfabrikant
Bernd Grohe.
Mélanie Eppenberger sagt,
sie sei zwei-, dreimal pro Woche
im Toggenburg.
Wohnen tun sie, ihr Mann und die drei
Kinder im zürcherischen Zollikerberg.
Sind Sie glücklich damit,
wenn Sie es so sehen?
Sehen ist das eine,
das Haus erleben, das andere.
Wir machen sehr gute Erfahrungen
mit dem Haus.
Die Menschen sind gerne im Haus
und bleiben auch gerne.
Ich glaube, Architektur ist etwas,
das man nicht einfach
auf dem Papier beurteilen kann.
Man muss es auf sich wirken lassen.
Erleben?
- Erleben.
Ja, ich finde es toll,
wenn die Menschen das schätzen,
was hier steht
und sie den Ort auch geniessen.
Okay, gehen wir ihn auch geniessen.
- Genau.
Als Mäzenin
sieht sie sich dennoch nicht.
Es ist und bleibt ein Business.
Ich glaube, das Toggenburg
braucht keine Wohltäter.- Ja.
Ich finde es immer problematisch,
wenn man sagt,
ich würde fürs Toggenburg
etwas Gutes tun.
Das Toggenburg liegt mir am Herzen.
Bei uns ist sicher ...
... der Wunsch da,
langfristig eine
wirtschaftliche Struktur aufzubauen,
die sich selbst tragen kann und
zur Lebensqualität im Tal beiträgt.
Ihr Ziel sei ein ganzjähriger natur-
und kulturnaher Tourismus.
Man wolle weniger
vom Wintergeschäft abhängig sein.
Heute ist die Vertreterin
einer Textilfachschule vor Ort.
Ihr Wunsch:
eine Modenschau auf dem Chäserrugg.
Ich war letztens hier
und sah dieses wunderbare Gebäude
von Herzog & de Meuron.
Es ist fantastisch.
Es ist einzigartig, weil es Hand-
werkskunst und extrem ästhetisch ist
und es wirklich auch den Kunst-
und Designaspekt widerspiegelt.
Ich finde, es hat viel Nähe zu uns,
weil wir genau das auch machen.
Wir haben Handwerkskunst,
wir sind ästhetisch unterwegs
und das Design spielt
eine sehr wichtige Rolle für uns.
Und ich glaube, Fashion auf dem Berg
hat es so noch nie gegeben.- Ja.
Auf der Piste erklären mir
Herr und Frau Eppenberger dann
ihre eher eigenwillige Philosophie
des Skifahrens.
Sie sprechen von Entschleunigung.
Weniger Gäste,
die aber mehr geniessen
und dafür einen guten Preis bezahlen.
Also keinen
"geschmäcklerischen Billigtourismus".
Das ist einer ...
Das ist Herzog & de Meuron,
schön in die Alpställe eingepasst.
Da kam auch mal ein Kritiker
und meinte:
"Du, wieso brauchtet ihr
diese Stararchitekten hier?"
"Das sieht ja aus wie ein Alpstall."
Da sagte ich: "Eben darum."
- Darum.
Hätte ich einen einheimischen
Architekten angestellt,
wären es Gipfeldiamanten
in Blau, Rot und Orange geworden.
Oder?
- Ja.
Dass man auch bei einem
kleinen Objekt wie diesem Kiosk
den Aufwand nicht gescheut hat, den
schön und zurückhaltend zu machen.
Es ist ein Holzgebäude.
- Mit Holz.
Sodass es
wie eine Alphütte aussieht.
Das ist unsere Strategie.
Sie haben es vielleicht gesehen:
Wir haben keine einzige Werbung
gesehen, seit wir im Gebiet sind.
Das ist auch ein wichtiger Teil
der Strategie.
Zu sagen: Wenn der Gast hier ist,
möchten wir ihm Natur zeigen,
und nicht noch mehr Werbung,
die er schon die ganze Woche sieht.
In Schneekanonen
investieren sie eher widerwillig.
Pistenplanierungen im Sommer
sind tabu.
Dann schon lieber eine weitere Zwi-
schenstation von Herzog & de Meuron.
Das ist auch etwas Interessantes:
Sehen Sie sich das Gebäude an!
Die Architekten sagten mir,
dass es in den Bergen ...
... ja nicht nur Hütten
als bekannte Form gebe.
Es gebe auch die Galerie
auf den Passstrassen.
Dieses Gebäude
ist einer Galerie nachempfunden.
Damit ist es für das Auge
auch nicht fremd.
Wenn Sie sich das ansehen,
scheint das nicht fremd,
obwohl es ein Betonbau ist.
- Mhm.
Weil es einer Galerie
nachempfunden ist.
Die Rechnung werde aufgehen.
Ohne Corona hätten sie dieses Jahr
erstmals Dividenden auszahlen können,
sagen sie.
Auf der anderen Seite
bei den Bergbahnen Wildhaus.
Hier setzt man jetzt voll
auf die Karte Familie,
insbesondere kleine Kinder,
die erstmals auf den Brettern stehen.
Aber auch erwachsene Anfänger.
Diese Kundschaft
nennen sie hier "First Touchers".
Mit dieser Strategie werde man
Erfolg haben, meinen die Wildhauser -
auch ohne
ein gemeinsames Winterticket
mit den Nachbarn vom Chäserrugg.
Allerdings: Der zweite Corona-Winter
setzt den Wildhausern,
wie vielen anderen, schwer zu.
Es ist der 21. Dezember.
Das lukrative Weihnachtsgeschäft
steht eigentlich vor der Tür.
(Funk) Verstanden, antworten.
Und doch
muss Geschäftsführer Urs Gantenbein
Bahnen und Gastrobetriebe
jetzt schliessen.
Guten Morgen miteinander.
- Morgen.
Alles klar?
- Bei uns schon.
Bei uns auch noch.
Hallo zusammen.
- Wir müssen das Gebiet schliessen.
Hoi, Jürg.
- Ja, Schlegel, hoi.
Nein, Zogg, der Berner.
- Ja, genau, hoi.
Wie geht's? Mit der Maske
erkennt man sich nicht.
Doch, jetzt kann ich es sogar lesen.
Der Schliessungsbefehl
kam von der St. Galler Regierung.
Gantenbein informiert das Personal.
Ihr habt es vernommen:
Die Direktive des Kantons
und des Bundes ist eindeutig:
Ganz klar keine Bewilligung für alle
Skilifte und Bergbahnbetriebe.
Das kam gestern auch schriftlich,
als Verordnung.
Klar und deutlich geregelt.
Was wir noch diskutiert haben,
ist auch geregelt:
Ausflugstourismus, Winterwanderwege
und all das.
Das war eine Variante.
Das ist alles auch gestrichen.
Erst ärgerte es mich,
jetzt denke ich, es ist fast besser,
alles ganz runterzufahren.
Alles zu heisst wirklich alles zu.
Wir werden das erste Mal ein paar
Tage ein unbesetztes Büro haben.
Wir schalten
den Anrufbeantworter ein.
Wirklich mal richtig zu,
wie wir das noch nie hatten.
Das ist einmalig.
Immerhin:
Man habe Kurzarbeit beantragt.
Die Löhne könne man für den Moment
vorschiessen.
Das soll nicht euer Problem sein.
Wir haben noch Geld.
Wir können bezahlen,
das ist nicht das Problem.
Andererseits
geben wir kein Geld aus.
Ausgabenmässig gibt es momentan
nichts mehr, das wir kaufen.
Ja ...
Ich wünsche schöne Weihnachten.
Trotz allem.
Du warst 40 Jahre an Weihnachten
nicht zu Hause.- Yes.
Ich war 30 Jahre nicht zu Hause.
Bei den meisten ist es wohl auch so.
Achtet darauf, euren Frauen
nicht auf den Geist zu gehen.
* Lachen *
Und umgekehrt auch.
Ihr am Frauentisch.
Geht ab und zu raus.
Die sind sich nicht gewohnt,
dass man dann zu Hause ist.
Die Schliessung der Bahnen ist
in diesem Jahr besonders ärgerlich.
Die Saison lief bis jetzt gut an.
Ich bin schon viele Jahre dabei
und wir kriegten selten
so pünktlich Schnee -
zusammen mit der Beschneiung,
die auch funktionierte,
weil wir kalte Temperaturen hatten.
Es lief nahezu perfekt an.
Auch toll dieses Jahr: Wir konnten
die neue Bahn präsentieren.
Die kam sehr gut an.
Bis jetzt lief es
eigentlich wirklich sehr gut.
Bis heute
waren wir total gut im Rennen.
Dann machen sich die Arbeiter auf
zum vorübergehenden Abbau
der Infrastruktur.
Der St. Galler Bergbahnen-Lockdown
dauert schlussendlich
aber weniger lange als befürchtet:
Ende Dezember gibt der Kanton
grünes Licht für die Wiedereröffnung.
Dennoch wird bis Ende Saison
ein Loch in der Kasse bleiben.
Insbesondere auch,
weil in den Gastronomiebetrieben
die Einnahmen rund 90 % tiefer sind
als letztes Jahr.
Die Bergbahnen Wildhaus haben - genau
wie ihre Nachbarn vom Chäserrugg -
beim Kanton
Härtefallentschädigung beantragt.
Ob sie diese Gelder
vom Kanton erhalten,
war bei der Fertigstellung
dieses Films noch nicht klar.
Es ist Mitte Februar.
Mein letzter Besuch im Toggenburg.
Ah, doch, da ist er,
mit der blauen Jacke.
Ich habe einen Termin
bei dem für den Tourismus
verantwortlichen Regierungsvertreter,
Wirtschaftsminister Beat Tinner.
Die Corona-Erfahrung werde auch
den Bahnen zu denken geben müssen,
sagt er.
Für den sog. Eisernen Vorhang
zwischen den beiden Bahnen
im Obertoggenburg
habe er kein Verständnis.
Mittel- und langfristig
werde man so Gäste im Tal verlieren.
Und er warnt: Dem St. Galler
Wintertourismus wehe inskünftig
eine steifere Brise entgegen.
Zwei meiner Vorgänger
haben sich ernsthaft
um das gemeinsame Skiticket bemüht.
Die Verhandlungen
scheiterten jedes Mal.
Ich sagte bei meinem Amtsantritt
ganz klar,
dass ich, wenn der Wunsch
zu Gesprächen bestehe,
bereit dazu sei, die zu führen.
Aber vom Departement, von mir aus,
wird es keine
entsprechende Initiative geben.
Wir versuchen viel mehr,
unsere Wirtschaftsförderung
neu zu fokussieren,
indem wir wirklich
auch Richtung Innovation gehen
und etwas weg vom Tourismus.
Wir sind überzeugt,
dass sich der Kanton St. Gallen
im Tourismusbereich
neu justieren muss.
"Neu justieren" heisst weniger Geld
für den Tourismus.
Wir werden versuchen, weniger Mittel
in den Tourismus zu investieren.
Wieso?
Weil die Wertschöpfung im Kanton
St. Gallen bei der Industrie liegt.
Da muss sich jeder Kanton
gut überlegen,
wo die Stärken und Schwächen liegen.
Die Stärken liegen bei uns
in den wertschöpfungsintensiven
Industriebetrieben.
Weniger öffentliche Gelder -
das wäre doch ein Grund mehr,
um eine Lösung im Kulturkampf
der Bergbahnen zu finden.
Für mich heisst das,
ein letztes Mal nachfragen.
Ich fahre ins Rheintal, nach Buchs.
Hier,
vis-à-vis des Schlosses Werdenberg,
wohnt der Verwaltungsratspräsident
der Bergbahnen Wildhaus,
Jakob Rhyner.
Der 70-Jährige leidet seit dem
fünften Lebensjahr an Kinderlähmung
und er hat gerade
eine intensive Behandlung
nach einem Prostatakrebs hinter sich.
Über die Livecam schaut er, was
auf den Pisten von Wildhaus los ist.
Sein Kampfgeist für die Bergbahn
ist ungebrochen.
Machen Sie weiter,
solange Frau Eppenberger
auf der anderen Seite ist?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Sicher ...
... gebe ich den Kampf nicht auf,
also, wenn wieder etwas
von feindlicher Übernahme kommt.
Aber ich will das nicht
auf eine Person beschränken.
Wenn sie noch schlauer wird
und doch mal einsieht,
dass wir
zusammenarbeiten sollten ...
Ich hoffe,
dieser Winter zeigt ihr das.
Mélanie meint immer,
was sie wolle, sei eine Fusion.
Wir haben immer gesagt, wir
seien für eine Fusion auf Augenhöhe.
Was ist das?
Ja, dass man alles korrekt,
Schritt für Schritt prüft.
Gutachten einreicht,
neutrale Expertise ...
Das Zweite wird dann mal sein,
was für Strategien man hat
und das Dritte das Personelle.
- Ja.
Was sie macht: Sie will die Mehrheit
unserer Gesellschaft.
Das ist an sich nicht verboten,
das darf sie.
Dann wäre eine Fusion ganz anders.
Könnten Sie damit leben?
- Nein.
Solange ich da mitmache ...
... übernimmt uns niemand.
Er sei überzeugt, seine Aktionäre
möchten das Schicksal der Bahn
nicht in die Hände
eines einzelnen Investors geben.
Für die Eppenbergers ihrerseits gilt:
Wer zahlt, befiehlt.
Sie würden am liebsten
das ganze Obertoggenburg
nach ihren Vorstellungen entwickeln.
Ich bin nicht jemand,
der die Möglichkeit hat,
einfach etwas Geld zu verstreuen.
Es muss aufgehen. Und wenn ich
so grosse Beträge investiere,
möchte ich schon darauf achten,
dass es mir
nicht aus den Händen rutscht.
Ja, ja.
Ich verlasse das Obertoggenburg
mit gemischten Gefühlen.
Ich habe eine schöne Region
mit netten Menschen kennengelernt.
Aber auch zwei Bergbahnbetreiber,
die sich in ihren gegensätzlichen
Positionen bestärkt fühlen.
Wie man hier wieder zum
gemeinsamen Skiticket kommen könnte,
das sich so viele wünschen,
bleibt mir schleierhaft.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021